la inseminación intrauterina también
conocida como inseminación artificial es
un procedimiento que se realiza para
ayudar a una mujer a quedar embarazada
el sistema reproductor de una mujer
incluye la vagina
el cuello del útero
el útero
las trompas de falopio
y los ovarios
durante el ciclo de menstruación mensual
uno de los ovarios libera un óvulo en un
proceso denominado ovulación
después de la ovulación el óvulo ingresa
a una trompa de falopio
una mujer tiene más probabilidades de
quedar embarazada si tiene relaciones
sexuales en los días justo antes durante
o después de la ovulación
durante este periodo un espermatozoide
del líquido reproductivo del hombre
denominado semen puede fertilizar el
óvulo cuando avanza por la trompa de
falopio
y la inseminación intrauterina puede
realizarse si una mujer tiene problemas
para quedar embarazada una condición
conocida como infertilidad o también si
una mujer desea concebir un hijo sin una
pareja masculina
antes de la inseminación intrauterina es
posible que la mujer reciba medicamentos
para la fertilidad que provoquen que
libere más de un óvulo durante la
ovulación en un proceso denominado
lavado de semen el esperma del hombre se
separa del líquido del semen esto
concentra el esperma elimina los
desechos y elimina las hormonas que
podrían causar calambres en el útero si
la pareja masculina es completamente
infértil también conocido como estéril o
si la mujer no tiene una pareja
masculina se usará para el procedimiento
el esperma previamente lavado y
congelado de un donante
el doctor monitorear a los ovarios para
detectar la ovulación la inseminación
intrauterina debe realizarse justo antes
o después de que una mujer óvulo
para que el óvulo esté disponible para
la fertilización
durante el procedimiento la mujer
permanecerá acostada sobre una mesa para
exámenes se insertará una herramienta
denominada especuló en su vagina para
que el médico pueda ver el cuello del
útero se cargará una jeringa con una
pequeña cantidad de líquido con esperma
lavado luego la jeringa se colocará en
un tubo largo y delgado denominado
catéter
el médico insertará el catéter en la
vagina
la punta del catéter se introducirá a
través de la apertura del cuello del
útero hasta el útero una vez que el
catéter está dentro del útero el medico
inyectará el esperma
luego se retirarán el catéter y el
espéculo
es posible que la mujer deba permanecer
acostada durante aproximadamente 10
minutos